non je suis un peu gêné là parce que je
me demande c'est pas un peu indécent de
venir alors que tant de gens portent
encore le deuil de mandela ouais c'est
vrai que pas nous les blancs on n'a pas
de figure comme ça non non non enfin tu
vois quelqu'un qui aurait fait de la
prison qui à un moment aurait été
libérée qui aurait décidé de fonder un
parti qui aurait choisi une iconographie
un peu un doux pour montrer son
ouverture d'esprit et qui à un moment tu
vois ce serait battu pour droits des
blancs avoir un espace vital
en europe a jamais connu ça
finalement mandela je trouve que c'est
une sorte de lilian thuram et avec une
vie plus facile
non mais c'est vrai et mandela ils
étaient maintenus à l'écart des blancs
alors que thuram il devait jouer avec
j'ai comme tout le monde j'ai regardé la
cérémonie les organisateurs ont espéré
du beau temps et puis hollande est
arrivé
forcément là bas on l'appelle pas
monsieur le président mais monsieur
mouche on tue c'est
enfin ils sont un peu con il aurait dû
organiser les funérailles dans le désert
de namibie avec hollande et remplissez
les puits pour trois mois c'est vraiment
c'est mal choisi alors quelques couacs à
la cérémonie obama étaient traduits par
un type qui ne maîtrisaient pas le
langage des signes moi j'ai remarqué
tout de suite il faisait des fautes
d'accord on repasse est simple puisque
parfait c'est parce que quand tu fais ça
alors que c'est ça pour la conjonction
de subordination qui va faire la
circulation aux carrefours
mais
ceci dit ceci dit on dit mandela est
mort mais j'ai envie de dire est ce qu
on en est sûr
parce que moi j'ai réfléchi tu vois le
jour de sa mort son biopic sortait en
angleterre moi je connais un peu les
attachés de presse
on dit qu'un tel est mort et pas qu'on
le retrouve aux [ __ ] ou chez
sébastien
c'est
politique nationale ah oui en ce moment
après la bretagne la région qui fait
beaucoup parler c'est la centrafrique
[Rires]
en eau
la grande rengaine on devrait on ne
devrait pas intervenir tout seul comment
ça c'est chez nous
tel manquerait plus qu'on délègue la
sécurité intérieure aux [ __ ] et aux
américains froid il a vu ce que ça a
donné un des panneaux de signalisation
écrit en gothique où le jazz sais pas ce
qui est pire
non mais hollande a dit de soldats sont
tombés pour la france donc c'est donc si
je donc sinon ça chez nous un moment ça
suffit les zones de non-droit ça suffit
les flics peuvent aller partout
alors bien sûr non c'est tout ça c'était
une blague c'est des pitreries ge
évidemment c'est pas chez nous mais ça
que les us et coutumes là bas ne sont
pas les mêmes jerry seah quand tu mets
défaut lacoste des claquettes c'est pour
boire un pastis avec le voisin c'est pas
pour le découper
et moi je trouve que c'est normal que
l'on se soit intéressé à la centrafrique
serait quand tu regarde la carte de
l'afrique la centrafrique si au milieu
on dirait la corrèze
s'est super bien isolée pas d'accès à la
mer que de la forêt et culturellement
que des bibelots que kiel chirac
[Applaudissements]
bon il y va on sait que c'est pour se
faire applaudir c'est bien ça on dirait
mireille mathieu quoi dès qu'il dépasse
la frontière il fait un carton
bon il y aller doucement au prudemment
le mec il est venu il n'est pas sorti de
l'aéroport bon sinon c'est comme tu
prenais la ligne 1 du métro tu t'arrêtes
à la concorde tu dis bonjour aux
clochards tu remontes dans le crâne seat
arrive à neuilly et tu dis [ __ ] la
concorde ça craint
quand j'ai regardé les attributs la
centrafrique paraît que système scolaire
calqué sur le système français
bon il ya sept chirurgiens pour tout le
pays par deux si tu enlèves les
vétérinaires et est pas vraiment donc
pas vraiment d'industrie système
éducatif nul tu m'étonnes collante s'y
sentent à l'aise
restauration un cafetier niçois
proposent trois prix différents pour son
café un café c'est cet euro un café s'il
vous plaît c'est 2 euros 50 bonjour un
café s'il vous plaît c'est un euro 40 et
paraît que c'est une manière de lutter
contre la politesse c'est quand même
frustrant moi je perds et moi je
préférais le payer 15 euros juste pour
lui dire et [ __ ] et le café c'est
quand
[Applaudissements]
érotisme jean claude mas c'est
l'inventeur du nichon qui sécrètent de
l'huile de vidange
par lui c'est à croire il n'a pas
inventé une prothèse mais un sextoy pour
les partouzards qui bosse chez feu vert
ou speedy
économie héros est parti en chine pour
vendre de l'énergie nucléaire on aura
vraiment tout vu un héros qui vend de
l'énergie
[Rires]
icône gouvernementales alors montebourg
c'est encore énervé chaque semaine ils
veulent pas ta ta ta ta ta qui l'eût cru
un le gars de bourg-en-bresse teigneux
comme un corse à qui on verra retirer
son permis de chasse
le type il a tout fait on va [ __ ]
dehors me talons lacés les et florence
il a réuni n'a rien souhaité on dit que
montebourg n'est pas entendue c'est faux
la preuve s'il n'était pas entendue en
face personne rigolerait
coupe du monde 2014 c'était le fameux
tirage hors compétition qui aura valeur
de test politique pour taubira on verra
si le programme de réinsertion des
délinquants fonctionne
pas cette coupe du monde c'est une
chance surtout pour ribéry c'est quand
même au brésil le pays la chirurgie
esthétique
en fait l'équipe de france ne va pas
être en concurrence avec les autres
équipes mais juste en concurrence
directe avec les matchs de sorties de
bureaux sur les plages de copacabana
c'est là que ça va jouer tout ça
le groupe est intéressant équateur
honduras suisse on dirait l'itinéraire
des stups
[Rires]
depuis les pays producteurs jusqu'à
celui qui accueille l'argent des cartels
en fait on n'y va pas pour jouer au foot
mais c'est juste pour prendre des
contacts pour les futurs go fast
fait divers la crise nous amène à
quelques actes sordides récemment des
mecs qui ont un passé dans les fractions
en veulent aux côtés ont kidnappé une
chèvre ils l'ont tué l'ont passé au
barbecue alors on sait tout ça grâce à
l'adn des prévenus qu'on la retrouvait
entre les pattes de la bête
ça peut se comprendre c'était une chèvre
angora ch -
non mais au moins avec une chèvre la
seule et mystique tu peut choper c'est
un rhume des foins
pragmatique
bonne nouvelle ah oui l'état efface la
dette de 4 millions de l'humanité un bas
du coup j'ai acheté l'humanité sursis un
peu mon journal du coup alors en
feuilletant le journal j'ai compris
pourquoi il serait une telle dette le
seul annonceur que j'ai trouvé dans le
métro de mardi dernier c'est la sncf
pour annoncer la grève
à bâle d'années pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu